Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for numb Monday,
November 20th,
2017 right off the bat.
The first thing you should notice is my hushed fucking tone.
That a hush tone,
a hushed fucking tone.
Uh,
my daughter is sleeping downstairs.
It's like five 30 in the fucking morning.
And uh,
this the only time I'm going to have to do this podcast if I wanted to kind of
come out on time today.
So that is what I'm doing.
Um,
I was with my daughter all day.
Yesterday was awesome.
Nia went out with some friends and then she went out to fucking dinner and,
uh,
I just sat there.
We watched the Patriots Raiders.
I had taped the Celtics,
um,
hawks game.
I watched a little bit of the Dallas Philly game cause on inside the NFL.
I said Dallas was going to win
it.
My only reasoning was divisioned rivalries.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
look how bad the buffalo bills got fucking raped yesterday by the San Diego
chargers for whatever fucking reason.
They're going to give us a tough game.
They're at least gonna cover this spread one goddamn time for the simple fact
that we see him twice a year going back to like 1960 back in the AFL,
you know,
so,
um,
I was wrong.
I'm big enough to say that I was wrong.
Carson Wentz I guess six foot five unbelievably mobile a bit.
Eagles put a thumping on him.
I'm a big enough man to say I was wrong.
I'm a big enough man to let you know that I'm sitting here drinking tea all
alone.
Um,
so yeah,
I just did that and was just a hanging out with my daughter do it.
She's amazing.
She really is amazing.
She is like all over the place.
You can say Mama now and she can say dot.
Dot.
But she doesn't know what they mean.
You know,
and she doesn't know when the word ends.
So you say Mama and she just goes Mama,
Mama,
mama say data Joko like mum,
Mum MCHA come on and say dad,
Dad,
dad.
That,
that an important in myself.
So just smile at me and like the fuck is with you.
When she just crawls away,
she could stand,
she can let go with stuff,
still stand.
Um,
for good,
like a,
I don't know,
they could records like eight or nine seconds and you always think that they're
gonna like fall back and hit the head,
drives you nuts.
But some reason they just,
they sit right down in there.
But,
um,
I dunno,
I still don't trust the whole,
still don't trust the whole thing.
And uh,
I did the classic dad moment,
someone's bought,
somebody bought us a toy that I think is a little advanced for my kid.
And it was a,
you'd like the walkers that old people have.
This is like the same kind of thing except it's uh,
you know,
it has a smiling cow's face on it and sing songs on the front.
But essentially it's an old person walker.
So my daughter was pushing it around like on her knees first and then she
started standing up.
What I did was I put my iPhone slightly in front of it,
you know,
cause they love any sort of computer screen.
MMM.
And,
uh,
she was,
you know,
started taking steps with it or anything,
but there's like no break on it.
It's like really fucking dangerous.
So I always have to be hovering over.
So the one time I go to film or doing it and no,
I'm not going to show you this footage.
MMM.
She fucking starts to walk and I'm filming her and all of a sudden she like
leaned back and the whole thing like tipped over on us.
She fell down and hit her head.
She was on the rug doctor capitated area.
But uh,
if I were to show you that video,
you'd see the second she was in danger,
I fucking threw the camera down and tried to catch her as opposed to most of
these fucking parents out there.
I swear to God,
it's like they're trying to put them in bad positions and then the kid falls
down and you hear the parents laughing.
They don't even try to help them cause it all giddy thinking like this is going
to get me a bunch of hits.
But I haven't seen this one.
There's some kid,
I guess somebody was telling me like hanging from something and falls into a
fucking fish tank.
Breaks the fish tank or something.
That's water.
That's glass,
that's dead fish.
That's the kind of shit used to get you sent to bed.
The second year parents site,
they'd be like,
dude,
what the fuck are you doing?
Okay.
They didn't say,
dude,
but everything else they said.
Now the parents just sit there and they,
you know,
it's like watching one of those nature shows,
like anytime they show a snake eating,
somehow it always finds a fucking mouse Dina Long.
You'd have to sit there following that goddamn snake around with an entire
camera crew.
Yeah.
Think keeps turning around looking at,
you're trying to strike you if freaking it out.
Right.
Bless you and your camera crew.
We'll make an all that God damn nose.
You're going to scare all the mice away,
but somehow they always seem to capture the moment the snake fights the other
snake.
You know?
It kills a rabbit.
It kills a fucking bird.
I want to know why all of these fucking people out there,
right.
All of these animal lovers that talking about the Japanese beaten all those
dolphins to death in the cove.
They're talking about don't leave your dog,
you know,
in a,
uh,
in a car with the windows up,
all of that shit.
What about these mice?
Okay.
On these theses fucking nature shows.
I think I've told this before,
I watched one,
one time diff following this snake through the,
we'll say air quote woods.
Okay.
The snake is completely oblivious of the goddamn camera crew.
They must be just tippy toeing around bright craft services just off in the
distance,
you know,
so they got one camera team is following with this mouse.
The other team is following like this rattlesnake or something.
So the mouse goes down into the hole and then the snakes goes down in the hole.
And then next thing you know,
I'm in the hole to the camera.
These in like the giant living room part.
Okay.
The open area,
the great room,
the room over the garage,
if you will,
of this whole,
okay.
The game room.
The man cave.
Right.
Okay.
And,
uh,
the camera's already in there.
The fucking mouth sustain and they're like,
what the fuck?
You know,
like Joe Peshy,
Goodfellas.
Like,
ah,
now the second sees the camera and then the snake comes in and kills the thing.
I want to know,
Peter,
they're so busy,
you know,
wrapping themselves around some fucking half dead armadillo layman and the
streets.
Where the fuck are they on this issue?
Okay.
How in God's name could that camera crew possibly and all the fucking holes in
the woods of all the fucking mice in the gather and mice in the woods.
I Dunno,
right?
Of all the fucking rodents in the God damn woods.
How the hell did they know that this fucking mouse was going to go down that
fucking hole and that snake that they will falling was going to follow that
mouse down into that hole ended that part of the whole,
okay.
There's only one way people,
it was just set up.
Okay.
Set up the same way they set up those sharks to look like a bunch of lunatics
when they hang that fucking steamship round hanging off the goddamn boat
steamship round.
Everybody.
I told you I'd work it in just basically half the hindquarters of a cow.
They got that hanging off the side of the boat,
right?
The great white shark shows up.
It's got that Arsenio thing where,
you know,
when it smells,
it shows way too much gumps making it not as sympathetic character,
which is why I think when they brought our cineo back,
it didn't last that long.
I think personally,
I don't think it was because of the talent of the man.
You know,
go back and watch coming to America,
going blow for blow with Eddie Murphy,
you know,
right.
Saint Day with these great white sharks.
Yeah.
Majestic beautiful too.
And their fucking job.
God forbid you got crooked teeth in America telling Ya
the mice have crooked teeth.
They get pointy teeth.
Right.
I didn't meat eaters
the fuck does a mouse seat.
It's gotta be,
it's gotta suck.
When you figure out that in the pecking order of nature here,
you're just sort of this,
uh,
like a slider.
You liked this appetizer.
Like there's,
you know,
all of that share Christ.
They're fucking like rabbits.
It's like rabbits have to produce the way they do or a bunch of other species
die.
Okay.
And I imagine some egg head with the lab coat would say that eventually human
beings would die unless we ate a plant based diet,
fruits and vegetables,
grains and nuts.
I'll get into this shit later on.
You know,
I,
I watched this video saying that,
you know,
meat and butter and shit and eggs,
dairy wasn't that bad.
So you know what happens the second you fucking say that,
uh,
you know,
this food isn't bad.
A bunch of people,
other non experts come out of the fucking woodwork and start telling you about
the videos that they,
that they just watched and the shit that they think is right.
You know,
it's literally like these fucking food people in nutrition people I'm done with
them.
Okay.
You know what they like?
They like religious people where they think God loves them best.
Their story about God.
Buddha,
Mohammed,
Jesus,
h o G.
H.
Right.
Okay.
I don't want to start a race war here.
It's not a race war,
a religious war here,
but you got to mid cheeses is the coolest stat of all of them.
You know?
Hey Man,
like you guys want to see me walk on water?
I mean just doing all these tricks,
right?
He's like a fucking lounge act in Vegas.
She's pulling all the fucking bread and the fish out.
You know,
in fairness to Muhammad,
I have not read one word about them.
I've never read the Qur'an.
I'd never even read the Bible,
you know,
in the afterlife.
I just hope I die in about in a group accident.
You know what I mean?
So that way we're all just kind of sitting there and I can kind of skate with
the smart kids.
You know,
when the teacher would come in.
Did anybody,
yeah,
read the short story last night.
Do y'all read it?
And everybody was kind of like,
yeah,
yeah.
Like try not to make eye contact then to do,
but start asking questions.
You like out,
fuck.
Come on man.
You start looking at the smart kid.
Like,
do put your fucking hand up and ask God damn quick answer these fucking
questions.
Listen,
my afterlife thinks going to be about,
you know,
I actually don't think it's going to be that bad.
Yeah.
Cause I am a big believer that either you're just dead like that poor fucking
mouse.
Oh,
the Arsenio Hall reboot the talk show.
She's dead.
I fucked that.
He's with my daughter.
I can hear her downstairs,
but she always wakes up this time anyways.
Um,
it's amazing when you're a parent.
The second you kids stirs in the Crib,
you fucking wake up,
still not getting paid.
I was sleep
probably what I'm talking about,
this fucking mouse right now,
five 47 in the morning,
Pacific coast time.
Um,
yeah.
I think either you're dead or you're just kind of show up and God's just like a,
yeah,
sorry about that.
You know,
it was just a big experiment.
I just,
you know,
I wanted to create a bunch of things that destroy each other.
I mean that's what happens.
If you do watch those nature shows the level of fucking murder that goes on out
in nature.
Okay.
Just all the time.
Does anybody die of old age,
like die a natural death in nature?
I think like elephants too,
but even then they're trying to walk back to that place that they remember.
And another always hyping up elephants.
But everything that they fucking remember,
it's like I get it.
I get it.
The Smart,
okay,
I get it.
There's 30,000 fucking muscles in their God damn nose.
Um,
I'm just fucking with you.
You gotta love element elephants,
you know,
rhinos and hippos and the cons of elephants.
You know what I mean?
I can feel like an elephant.
You kinda got a shot as long as their kids not around duck.
An elephant just kind of looks over it.
Yeah.
And it's just like I am at,
you know,
keep,
you can keep it distance.
Everything's fucking cool and rhinos and like hippopotamus is those fucking
things.
Sarah,
did I say rhinos and elephants?
So the cons of the elephants that I said it earlier,
did I say rhinos?
Hippos.
I don't even know.
Just fucking early rhinos and hippos are the cons of elephants.
You know what I mean?
Little short motherfuckers.
They didn't get the long nose right.
Just one of those guys coming out playing pickup hockey,
a pickup hoop,
and just taking it way too seriously.
And you just instinctively try to stay away from them before they blow your
fucking knee out.
If you watch one of those animal videos when like the hippo is like chasing
after the boat,
going under the water,
coming out of the water,
come on under the water,
coming out of the water.
It's like,
how the fuck is it producing that speed?
It's a tub of shit.
It's got a giant fucking head.
It's not aerodynamic whatsoever and it's got those little short legs.
I think it's doing the butterfly.
It's definitely not doggy paddle.
And when it gets going,
it's gotta be doing the butterfly.
Okay.
It's gotta be front legs forward,
you know,
and then both legs at the same time and the thrust and back.
Um,
okay.
Hippos like that fat kid at the pool who won't always goes into the pool with
his shirt on.
Right.
The fat kid in the fucking redhead like me.
I don't know why I never thought to do that.
I would just take the fucking sunburn.
It's going to turn it into color later.
Is it bill that are skin cancer?
Um,
anyways.
How about those New England patriots?
Okay.
Number one offense in the lowest rated defense.
I don't know about you guys,
but I think that spells success at January.
I'd have to look at the numbers and see how,
um,
okay.
Just see how they've been doing that over the last,
if the last few weeks,
if they've been letting up less points,
you know,
like God knows we got the shit kicked out of us.
Not even,
it was just the final quarter and a half.
We get the shit kicked out of us by the Kansas City chiefs.
Okay.
And everyone was going like,
Holy Shit,
Brady is old.
Here comes Kansas City.
And uh,
now look what happened.
Kansas City just lost to the fucking,
mmm.
New York giants,
the lowly New York giants.
Whoever thought you would say that.
Um,
all right.
Patriots schedule results.
Yeah.
2014.
That's what I want to fucking say.
2017.
Um,
to what in God's name is going on?
The health scores at ease.
All right,
here we go.
What the hell is going on with Kansas City?
Like how many fucking times can you do this to your fan base?
How many times can you get these fucking people excited only to turn around and
just shit the bed.
I don't understand it.
All right.
Preseason,
preseason,
preseason.
All right.
We gave up 42 points to the jets.
Then we gave up 20 points to this saints.
33 to the Texans.
33 to the panthers.
14 to the Buccaneers.
17 to the jets.
Seven to the falcons.
13 to the charges.
I would you want to right here.
16 to the Broncos,
but they stink.
And eight to the rate.
It's all right.
I think we're on the right then.
I thought I overheard that stat yesterday that we were last in team defense.
MMM.
It's nice to actually see us get pressure on the quarterback.
Uh,
I felt bad for Derek Carr though.
Jesus Christ.
I Dunno if the Raiders have been dropping as many passes as Tony Romo was
suggested.
But how great is Tony Romo in the broadcast booth?
The Guy knows the game and he's not afraid to shit on people.
I love it.
I feel like he,
he's doing everything that people think Chris Collins worth is doing.
And Chris Collins worth,
I thought was always fair all day.
Right now the patriots are just not getting it done.
Our defects like I always felt even back as much as it was annoying to hear.
Like I know Chris,
I'm watching the game.
He can't get mad cause the guys right on the other hand,
Tony Romo just take shots at guys.
It's fucking hilarious.
Like when he was sitting there saying how Tom Brady is the only player to ever
throw a touchdown pass in three different countries
being the United States of America,
uh,
England and uh,
now Mexico.
So Tony Romo goes,
yeah.
You know what that means?
He's a great quarterback and he's really old.
You know what I loved about it was funny listening to somebody make fun of Tom
Brady and then it was also funny knowing that you could just hear Tony Romo
pitch and do his girlfriend about how much attention fucking Tom Brady was
getting.
You know what I mean?
As he was trying to be a Dallas cowboys quarterback,
which God knows,
you know,
there's no fucking
okay,
I dunno what it,
whatever,
no good deed goes unpunished when you're a a quarterback for that team.
Forget the fact that Tony Romo had like 11 quarterback coaches and like 10
seasons or whatever for however long he was there.
You know,
I bet he was just going like,
oh,
you know,
every fucking thing I do in this fucking one horse Goddamn town that thinks that
this giant city
just gets scrutinized.
Oh,
but Tom Brady,
oh,
we sell fucking good luck and hey,
I'm just as good looking as dad guy.
Right.
You know,
he's thinking all of that shit.
Um,
so it's fun listening to shit on people.
I thought it was funny when he made fun of a Deion Sanders and that Deion
Sanders who was so above the conversation took the time to shit on him back.
I enjoy all of that.
Um,
anyways.
Hey,
by the way,
how great were the Mexican fans,
by the way?
You know,
I know a lot of Americans flew down there.
Well,
I guess we're all Americans,
right?
We're all part of North America.
All people from the United States of the Americas flew down for those games.
But um,
and the Raiders are the perfect team down there.
If I wasn't mistaken,
I thought I heard the patriots getting booed down there,
which made me feel great.
Nice to know.
We get respect down there too.
And um,
I dunno.
I thought it was a great game.
I am a little concerned though,
considering we lost Andrews Center and then we,
nick,
not nick cannon.
Marcus cannon is out and then the backup to Marcus Canon also has gone down.
So I don't know who the fuck are we playing next week,
but uh,
at they right now,
these patriots,
Sarah offensive lied better again,
healthy or that's going to spelled nothing but trouble come January.
Hang on.
It's my daughter's still.
Oh,
Jesus Christ didn't take him waking her up.
She's still downstairs making noise.
I got to talk even quieter.
I'm sorry.
I'll turn up the volume.
I'll turn everything up.
There we go.
Why don't you use the volume bill to your fucking advantage around,
I'm going to Westbrook,
not the breast as I swear to God the first Westbend podcast ever.
Um,
I'm not going to do that to you.
Okay.
All right.
I would never do that team.
Um,
all right,
let's talk about some more bullshit.
I watch my first Bruins game.
Am I in a half of two Celtics Games for the first time this year?
Uh,
first of all,
who are these 2017,
2018 Boston Celtics.
I barely recognized anybody's face,
but all I can tell you this is,
we're fucking young as shit.
Okay?
We kept chasing Tatum,
Ms Kits,
like fucking 20 years old.
We got Brown who I think they were seen as 20 years old.
That's our story in our starting five.
Um,
we got al Al Horford,
you know,
he's like the Zit Anal Chakra of the team.
We got mark is smart.
He's still on the team and I don't know who the fuck else we go.
Some other guy on there.
Um,
and all I know is we beat the Golden State fucking warriors
and they barely scored any points against us.
I forget what the final score was,
but like both teams will,
like in the fucking eighties.
Anyways,
all I know,
if it was under a hundred,
we made the warriors play our game.
Hmm.
We slowed it down.
Okay.
And God knows if you can beat the golden state warriors in November,
what's going to happen?
Come January.
I'll tell you right now.
The Celtics won one game against the warriors.
Does this mean they're going to sweep them in a seven game series?
They're going to start doing that shit.
Um,
I obviously think the worry is,
is still too strong.
I think we,
I think we have a better head coach and Brad Stevens.
Uh,
but I also think we still have to get past Lebron James and the Cavaliers first.
I just said,
I forget who the other guy was.
It's the guy from the fucking trade there with the plastic mask,
Kyrie Irving.
I'm very excited to watch them.
I watched my first Bruins game and they share and I watched the stinker rule
against the fucking Anaheim mighty ducks.
I think we beat the Kingston next night.
Um,
and I missed the game against the San Jose Sharks,
but I think Brad Marshawn is coming back,
but we're pretty,
we're pretty banged up right now.
Um,
but uh,
it's good to be banged up this time of year rather than the end of the year
because that's when you play for the trophy.
The,
I'm sorry,
I'm listening.
I think she went back to sleep.
All right,
cool.
Jesus Christ.
How much quieter can you fucking
damn kids.
I swear to God they spoiled Brat.
Spoiled Brat too.
What the fuck is going on with the Kansas City chiefs?
I don't get these guys.
I just don't get it.
Now the saints are coming on,
but when the saints come marching and they get fucking drew Brees and they have
a running game,
I actually fucking looked up yesterday.
Um,
but daughter fell asleep on my chest.
Right.
And it's just like all rookie move,
rookie move.
I should have had a fall asleep on the bed.
And then I could have got up and got on with my life for fucking 50 to 90
minutes.
So she's sleeping on my chest and I'm just like,
well how do I,
how do I make this time productive?
And I realized I'm inside the NFL.
How little I know about the players in the league.
I mean,
I was already working too hard on f is for family and I got the kid,
I barely know anybody.
So I started looking up the starting quarterbacks,
have every team trying to see how many I could name.
Um,
all right,
so here we go.
I swear to God,
I don't have them in front of me.
I'm going to try to remember as many as I can.
Okay.
Tom Brady,
the greatest of all time up there in New England.
Plaintiff Foxborough and he got tie Rod Taylor and Buffalo.
I don't give a fuck who was backup is.
I'm not going to waste my time memorizing a backups fucking name.
All right.
Until,
until they do something until they win the fucking job.
Did jets have Josh mccown,
Eli Manning the Patriot killer.
The Egos got who?
Carson Wentz and in the alias Joe Flacco,
the name you give to the cops.
What's your name?
Joe.
What?
Joe Flacco what?
Um,
oh,
then who the fuck to the Redskins?
Have you liked that you liked that?
What are his fucking name is just like 20 cars since I feel he's another guy
with this c name and it's not content.
Um,
Cam Newton.
Dan.
Okay.
Jacksonville has Blake Bortles Jamison Winston in Tampa Bay and then Jay Cutler,
Matty ice in Atlanta.
Drew Brees at the saint smartest weather.
Is it fucking,
uh,
the titans,
but I couldn't name any.
Anyways,
I just fucking try and I'm trying to test my fucking brain here.
All right.
Then you go to the bangles.
You got the fucking
the redhead there.
All right.
The giant ginger.
Andy Dalton with the fucking hipster haircut,
mocking my hairline.
Uh,
and then the Brown,
one of the great names and of all sports have does Sean Kaiser,
I love that name.
Is he a black guy?
Is,
is,
is he fucking celebrating Hitler's birthday?
You don't know.
I don't know.
Kaiser just sounds like a fucking German officer to me.
I don't know why.
All right.
And what do you got?
You got that guy out there,
uh,
for the lions.
What the fuck's his name?
Tommy Hilfiger.
I don't know why that name just popped in my head.
I'm almost won't come on the basket.
Eric.
Apple.
The fuck do they have,
I just went blank on his name.
Andrew Luck.
I see what the Indianapolis,
I know they got that dude from NC state backing him up.
Aaron Rodgers.
I know he's heard my ribs still feel why he's hurt.
Um,
I don't know who the vikings have.
The bears have some guide.
Mitchell fucking true.
Bisky or some fucking thing.
Alex Smith.
Zach Prescott.
The fucking
Texans.
Who the fuck do they get?
I know there's some fantasy football people just rattle and what they get that
kid from Clemson who got hurt
and then a Denver,
I always forget that guy's name.
Some regular name and his last name is like fucking oscillation or some shit.
I don't know who the fucking cardinals have the La rams have.
Uh,
the fuck is his name.
Jared Golf,
Philip Rivers,
Derek Carr.
And then this one killed me.
Cj.
Okay.
Beat hard jack off.
Murder your meat,
whatever his fucking last name is.
And then he got it out.
Russell Wilson.
See us?
Not Bad.
That was bad.
No.
Ask me to name all the receivers.
I can't name anybody.
That's what I knew.
I realized when I was on the inside of the NFL and I'm going to bore you guys to
death,
trying to fucking get caught back up.
You know what?
Fuck me over.
I,
when I stopped collecting football cards,
I'd love to get back into it,
but they won't do,
they won't just let you buy a whole set,
you know,
at least they wouldn't.
Last time I tried to collect like 10 years ago,
I think I'm gonna have to give in and start playing fantasy football.
No,
I'm just not going to know anybody.
Um,
all right.
I need to just promote some things here.
Um,
I'm doing a benefit tonight at the laugh factory in Long Beach.
If you want to come down and watch me do a headlining set and a wonderful comedy
club and watch all of the money,
go to,
uh,
go to the victims of the hurricane out there in Puerto Rico.
Um,
please come down.
There's some tickets left.
Alright.
That club has not been doing the greatest job promoting this fucking show.
All right,
so please come down.
I'll do a meet and greet afterwards.
I'll shake your hand,
I'll sign your fucking tits.
Whatever the hell you want me to do.
Um,
but I'll ask you first before I sign your tits before I get in trouble.
Oh,
also Jesus Christ.
all things comedy.
We got our new website up,
redesigned it and all that type of stuff.
I couldn't find the TV shows that we've made yet.
Those things should be coming up soon too.
So please check that out.
All things,
comedy.com and uh,
now for some sad news,
I even sat just an amazing life.
Malcolm Young of ACDC passed away and all the football,
I watched Jesse in the NFL.
I was a little perturbed.
That was a little annoyed that there wasn't any sort of tribute to Malcolm young
considering
he's arguably the greatest rock and roll rhythm guitarist of all time.
He's written so many classic rifts.
All of those ACDC albums and there's like four or five that are just absolute
masterpieces.
They're all great,
but he has five fucking masterpieces.
All right.
As much as I love pink Floyd,
as much as I love led Zeppelin,
I mean they're right there with them.
Masterpiece highway,
would it help masterpiece back in black masterpiece but to be rock masturbation,
power age,
masterpiece,
flick of the switch masterpiece.
Alright.
And if you don't fucking think they are,
it's because you're not.
You don't know it.
You know,
you don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
I even like for those about to rock,
everybody was all fucking Luke who's isn't as good as back in black and shut the
fuck up.
Um,
anyways,
I would have thought the NFL would have done something for how many years that
they've been playing hell's bells
and thunderstruck and all that.
Getting their stadiums all amped up.
And how many years did his band,
you know,
then come back on tour and sell out those same football stadiums.
How much money is he NFL?
You know,
it's a great partnership.
Dan made off of that band and during the off season when they tried to have
soccer in their stadiums and the fucking place is half full.
Who comes in to save the day?
Fucking Malcolm Young.
But this band ACDC,
it's some of the greatest rifts of all fucking time.
Okay.
You know,
um,
I was lucky enough to see him
how many times I see him.
I think I saw him three times.
I saw him in [inaudible] 86 and the who made,
who tour on the heat?
Secretor I saw his uh,
nephew who's now in the band.
Then I saw them.
Uh,
oh.
I think I only saw him twice based on my black ice.
I seen ACDC three times.
I saw some of the Black House tour and that was the last time I saw him.
And uh,
he's just the coolest,
greatest,
yeah.
Rock and roll rhythm guitarist of all time.
MMM.
Just the way they would,
they build a song.
I was listening to live wire.
Okay.
You know,
only he could just make those chords sound so fucking evil.
And the way he builds them it,
it's still gives me chills.
T and T,
I dunno if there's just too many overdose.
The way that song bills,
I know everybody knows the classics.
I'm gone shooting the whole second side of powerage,
downpayment blues,
all of that stuff.
It's just an absolute giant.
Um,
I dunno,
I thought,
did Google do a tribute to him?
I mean that's the level of guy that dad passed away here.
Uh,
but anyways,
thanks to him and his genius in that.
Unbelievable.
But that was my band growing up.
I was actually laughing,
listen to all that music.
I wasn't believing like sad that he was gone because I think he lives like such
an amazing life.
And um,
I was just thinking of all the fucking classes that I flunked in high school and
how depressed I was,
how stupid I thought I was.
And then I want to just go out and I would fucking get my piece of shit truck
and I would turn it on and pop in that cassette.
And then I would just go into fantasy world that I was in their band and knew
how to play guitar.
And then I would instantly be in a good mood again.
And I used to always sing on multiple choice tests that I knew I was flunking
and I was just guessing and I was running out of time.
That Bond Scott Lyric.
Uh,
I don't even remember what song is from that.
Take a chance.
Why you still got the choice,
rock and roll damnation.
That song would be playing in a loop,
as I was guessing.
Um,
I forget what I got on my se sats.
I got like a 300 something combined and a,
I'm going to tell you,
I tried,
I took a prep course,
I did everything and I just fucking shit the bed on it.
Yeah.
MMM.
And I'd love to tell you people that I,
that had a major effect on my life,
but it didn't.
Um,
anyway,
so let's read some,
uh,
so breast and peace,
Malcolm Young,
uh,
there's never going to be another one like it.
That's it.
I always thought he always thought,
hey,
Malcolm young and Phil Rudd with the two coolest guys in the band.
That was it right there.
Those two fucking guys.
Malcolm,
Phil Rudd sitting there with a cigarette dangling out of his mouth,
just fucking crushing it.
I think even Billy Joel sent,
you know,
that was the greatest live band he's ever seen.
Um,
speaking of which,
did anybody hear the Howard Stern interview with?
Um,
Billy Joel?
Jesus.
Fucking amazing.
What a town.
There's a guy I have to go see live.
I can't believe I've never seen that guy life.
I was such a Douche in the 80s.
If you didn't have a guitar,
I just thought you were the biggest pussy ever fucking watch this guy playing
his piano.
Two parents pay for the fucking your recital.
Meanwhile,
he's just total bad is,
I never owned this.
This is such a bad thing to say,
but I never realized how talented in what a Badass Billy Joe was.
I honestly didn't really even pay attention to the guy and silly started getting
hammered driving his car into the fucking front of people's houses.
You know,
I remember when he was singing like uptown girl and all that type of shit when I
was an uptown girl.
Loves that song where,
uh,
one of those songs where you sing in like,
you know,
he was in love with this girl across the tracks.
Like he was his bad ass guy and she's like,
dude,
you this little Jewish guy playing fucking piano.
That's about as safe as it gets.
You're,
you're a model citizen.
That's what I thought.
I didn't realize that he starts getting hammered driving his car into people's
houses and this is just trying to sit down and eat dinner.
And I was like,
Oh,
you know what?
I guess he is from the other side of the tracks.
Got a love of Booze Hound.
All right.
Speaking of which,
I'm 95 miserable days in,
I was hanging out with these two alcoholics his fucking weekend who are now
clean and they are both sitting there going,
yeah,
you know,
I don't miss it.
And I was just like,
oh yeah,
I do.
You know?
All right.
Oh,
look who's here?
Everybody.
Old Zip recruiter.
All right.
Separate crude,
everybody.
Are you hiring well?
Are you,
do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Talk about the satisfaction of employing it actually is a great,
that is a great feeling when you hire somebody,
you know,
knowing that you put a fellow American to work
right?
No one you can tell them what they,
what they can and can't do.
No one,
you can lord over them.
Um,
with ZipRecruiter knowing you can ruin their holidays with one simple phone call
and two of the best words in the English language,
you're fired with ZipRecruiter.
You can post your job to over 100 of the Web's leading job boards with just one
click.
So you can rest easy knowing your job is being seen by the right candidates to,
to how creepy is this coffee?
When I'm whispering then sip
recruiter,
I'm like,
that creep at work coming up behind you and your cubicle.
What are you doing this weekend?
Uh,
then ZipRecruiter puts its smart matching technology to work
actively notifying qualified candidates about your job within minutes of
posting.
So you receive the best possible matches.
That's why ZipRecruiter is different.
It's just different and it's okay with it.
Unlike other hiring sites,
ZipRecruiter doesn't depend on the right candidates finding you.
It finds them.
You can even get a headstart on the interview process by adding screening
questions
to your job.
Po.
Uh,
sorry,
I was checking on what time it is to see if I still have time to do cardio
before I had to get on with my day.
Um,
that's so exciting.
This copy is,
you can even get a headstart on in the interview process by adding screening
questions to your job posts to help identify the most qualified candidates yet.
Do you have a sex scandal in your past?
Um,
so you don't have to waste time sorting through a stack of resumes to find the
perfect fit.
This guy's perfect for the job.
Oh my God,
he fucked a cat.
Move onto the next one.
No wonder 80% of the employers who post on Ziprecruiter get a qualified
candidate through the site in just one day.
And the easy to use ZipRecruiter dashboard lets you manage your hiring process
from start to finish all in one place.
SIP recruiter to smartest way to hire.
Find out today.
Why is it
okay
as you has been used by growing businesses of all sizes and industries to find
out the most qualified job candidates with immediate immediate results.
And right now my listeners can post a job on ZipRecruiter for free.
That's right free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/bar that's said
[inaudible] dot com slash bar one more time.
Jesus Christ.
Try it one more time for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/bar
wow.
That was way too fucking long.
Huh?
He said,
I just feel like poor Moi.
Alright.
He looks sleep everybody.
He looks Hellickson.
There are a ton of online mass mattress retailers popping up these days.
Are there?
I have no idea.
All with a one size fits all solution to a better sleep.
Guess what?
One size doesn't fit all.
Okay.
Some people have a round ass if somebody have a flat ass.
Some people have long legs,
right?
Some people that have abnormally big ear lobes.
Now you wouldn't think that all this plays a factor in a comfortable good nights
sleep.
And I'm here to tell you different.
He likes sleep offers something that doesn't exist anywhere else.
A mattress personalized to your unique preferences and sleeping style that won't
set you back.
Thousands of dollars.
What exactly is a fucking sleeping style?
Uh,
you sleep reverse cowgirl like you're fucking possess.
Can imagine that.
Imagine if you fucking married the most beautiful woman in the world and she
just sat,
she slept sitting up in bed
like you go to sleep like at night honey,
and she would be laying back in the middle of the night.
It just,
you know,
that fucking
instinct.
You have that.
Should I open my eyes right now?
And you open your eyes and you look over and she was sitting up in bed,
fucking sleeping again.
Can imagine the first night you reach over and touch on her shoulder like,
hey honey.
All right.
What if she slept?
Sitting up with her eyes open.
Um,
Bill,
what if you finished reading this copy?
All right,
go to helix,
sleep.com/bird.
Take their simple two to three minutes sleep quiz.
They'll build a custom mattress.
That would be the best thing you've ever slept on for couples to even
personalize each side of the mattress,
which is the beginning of the end of the relationship and just seem like we're
not connecting anymore.
Know she said if she sat up sleeping,
she didn't like the craftmatic bed on her side.
Um,
you're accustom.
Mattress arrives for everyone.
Gq to cosmic from cosmopolitan to the New York Times are all talking about
helix.
Yeah,
cause you're paying them.
That's why I'm talking about it.
And once you try it out,
you'll know why your custom mattress arrives direct to your door in a week and
shipping is completely free.
Hmm.
Try It for 100 nights if it grows.
If you don't love it,
they'll pick it up and refund you in full.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Mr. White and Jesse Pinkman show up in their hazmat suits and they take it back.
See t a must read.
Hey Alex and I'll read whenever the fuck I want to read.
Go to helix,
sleep.com/bar right now and you'll get $50 towards your custom mattress.
That's Heloc sleep.com/burr for $50 off your order.
He looks sleep.com/burr.
All right,
the last one.
Thank Christ movement watches
Mvmt watches pronounced the movement was founded on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank.
Uh,
we get holiday shopping kit,
we get holiday shopping can be tough.
This is where they try to be down to earth,
but thanks to MVMT all that gift giving anxiety can disappear with the press of
a button.
These watches make the perfect purchase for just about anyone in your life.
Guy Or girl.
And remember they started only $95.
You know,
I just realized I have the volume turned up so high and they have to have the
Microsoft folks so close to my mouth.
I hope I don't sound like a mealy mouth jackass here.
And if I do,
I don't.
Well I guess I give a fuck.
I went up.
Brought it up,
huh?
All right.
Here we go.
Let me finish this here.
All right.
You've me talk about movement by these watches.
Make the perfect purchase for just about anyone in your life.
Guy Or girl.
And remember they started in [inaudible] 95 bucks and it's not chump change,
you know,
but for a good watch,
that's pretty good.
You've heard me talk about MVMT and I am sure you got yourself a watch.
Now let's finish your hobby,
your holiday shopping,
and get a MVMT watch for someone on your list.
MMM.
The holiday shopping season is here.
Yes.
We realize this.
This is why you're talking about the holidays with Mvmt.
You can skip the crowds and standing and crazy lines and find a gift of love at
prices that beat department stores at such great prices.
Moving to watch us make a wonderful holiday gift to classic design,
quality construction styled and styled minimalism.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to [inaudible]
dot com slash bar go to movement,
watches.com/bar join the movement.
All right,
that's it.
Okay.
Let's get into the questions here for this week.
I really apologize for the fucking West Marine,
but what do you already wanted from me?
All right,
Malcolm,
everybody a bill.
If you read this,
please refer to me as Steve.
Okay.
Steve reads,
I don't know why.
I'll never understand why my friends gave me such a hard time for attending the
ACDC show in Madison,
Wisconsin in 2001 being a high school,
Sophomore.
ACDC with it.
Shit,
as far as I was concerned,
but at the same time I didn't give a shit about top 40 him and let my
classmates,
no,
they had shit tastes ACDC never let up.
The most hard working band at the last 30 years.
They laminate a let down their fans
that just queued up if you want blood.
Oh,
what a fucking song that is.
The drums are insane in that perfect fucking drum beat.
Everything is just a shit.
They said there's nothing better.
Uh Oh.
Unless you're talking about the live album.
It's another amazing thing.
When I actually went to Glasgow,
Scotland,
I looked up to theater because I wanted to go in there where they recorded.
That thing doesn't exist anymore.
Anyways,
wanted to keep this short.
Ope your well,
you freckled cunt.
All right.
I don't know what you didn't really ask a question,
but I share your opinions on a ACDC and I've already talked about that shit.
All right.
Front flipping robot.
I actually saw that.
Hey there Billy 2000.
Did you see the video of the extremely agile robot that was going around the
last week?
Yeah,
it was kind of looked like a white dude doing flips.
Okay.
Um,
man,
build this thing is legit.
It's the first robot machine that I've ever seen where I thought I cannot disarm
miss y'all.
Yeah,
it's total robocop.
Even with the extreme flames or large amount of water,
I think it could kill me first.
You're right about all this robot shit.
Shit.
No one is going to be scared enough to stop this.
Also,
if we didn't make robots that could fight,
would we just be sending our guys into,
wait also,
if we didn't make robots that could fight,
why don't we just be sending our guys in to fight Russian or Chinese robots now?
He just went the exact opposite way.
Yeah.
This is how human beings we
out of fear and just the seduction of power.
We just keep making these fucking things.
It would be great if somehow we could all just get on the same page,
you know?
So we wouldn't do this type of shit to each other.
Cause this is,
it's not good.
It's not going to fucking end.
Well it really isn't,
but we're never going to get on the same pages.
So you don't,
when I,
dude,
I just sort of given to the fact that we're doomed to destroy ourselves.
All right?
And I have to think a robot debt has to be a quick death.
I would like to think that the Illuminati who is making these things to replace
all of us because they totally fit the bill for everything that a little bit out
he wants,
which is basically slaves do what we say do whatever we say whenever we say it.
And what if we said for years like assholes,
we like what do we fucking robots and what are the Illuminati do robots.
And they went out and they made the fucking things.
I just want to talk to all the nerds out there and everybody who thinks these
nerds are harmless,
these are fucking fucking egghead nerds who are so fucking smart that they are
going to destroy us because they are listening to the fucking sociopath's of
society,
the people boring power.
And they go out and they make these fucking things for them.
You stupid nerd fucking cunts.
Um,
I mean,
what do you do if you're held captive by a robot?
You just have to wait till the thing powers down and just hope you can find a
screwdriver and just start unscrewing shit and just fucking ripping out wires.
But you know what they gonna do?
They're gonna make these robots like the ones that are designed to kill all of
us.
They're going to make them out.
I like the same material as that door on the cockpit of a plane that nobody can
get into.
That's what it's going to be.
Unless you have the codes,
man.
Um,
yeah,
that's all.
Uh,
that's all scary shit.
And back when I was
just a fucking guy who was married and I didn't have a kid,
it wasn't as scary because I was already thinking like,
you know what?
I've had a great fucking life.
I really have done all kinds of stuff.
I got to
made a dream come true.
Becoming a comedian.
Everything else has been gravy.
I got a great wife,
but it's,
this is the kind of shit that I think that when I see robots,
I'm like,
you know,
I've had a great life
and that thing comes in and just grabs me by my throat just crushes my fucking
wind pipe.
That's what I'm going to be thinking.
I'm going to be thinking this robot,
as much as it's killing me right now was never going to know joy.
It's just going to no inputs.
Um,
anyways,
that's what I'm gonna say to the robot.
Yeah.
At least I know what happiness feels like
10 pro,
but gets all mad.
Shut the fuck up.
But if it could feel anger than it could feel joy.
All right.
Sorry.
Okay.
MMP advice a lady requests your advice on men.
Um,
okay.
I bill,
how are you?
I love your work.
Especially you're special and you're mm,
podcast advice.
I learned a lot from your advice about the male point of view.
That's really fucking feel like there's a lot of layers to that compliment and I
would be grateful for your insight.
All right.
I Dunno why you're listening to me,
but okay.
Here we go.
I have no fucking background whatsoever other than failing a lot.
All right.
No professional background.
I am a happily married woman with the toddler,
baby girl.
Ah,
isn't that the best?
And I'm currently pregnant with another girl.
He hit the lottery twice.
Um,
I am writing you,
I'm writing to you because by listening to it seems that in general you feel
that women have the upper hand in life.
However,
I disagree.
Well,
yeah,
the grass is always greener sweetheart.
MMM.
That is one thing that I always,
I do as feminists.
I'd say to them,
is there any scenario?
Is there even one scenario where you can think that,
hey,
um,
you know,
as far as men and women go in this scenario,
it's good to be a woman.
They can't do that because their whole business model falls to the fucking
ground.
Every fucking scenario.
It's still me.
You heard you're for us.
Is it everything out there is harder for a woman than why do you outlive us?
If your life is really that much more difficult than mine,
why do you outlive a man on average by like eight to fucking 10 years?
Let me guess.
Because the man is doing something wrong.
Blame the victim ladies.
Be exact thing you don't want done to yourself.
Do you ever think that maybe you have something to do with it?
Here's a classic one.
You know when my wife leaves the house,
you know,
and I think,
I think cool.
I got the house to myself right when I leave the house.
You know what my wife thinks,
what can I now text him and tell him to go out and go get me?
What can I add?
He's out there having fun.
Let me add a fucking air into it.
Um,
hey,
can you go to trader Joe's?
Could you just go to trade shows really quickly?
The Saturday before Thanksgiving and wade into that fucking black Friday food.
Fucking mosh pit.
Sorry,
that was my yesterday.
Anyways,
I disagree.
I think men have the upper hand in general,
especially when it comes to job prospects,
salary and sexual aggression.
So Jesus Christ,
here we go again.
Um,
what is sexual aggressions mean?
I don't even know what the fuck that means.
Um,
I would agree with job prospects and salary,
but I think the biggest fucking problem women have is you guys don't go out and
start enough businesses.
You keep coming working for men.
We've been fucking you over since day one.
At what point are you going to become self sufficient?
And I feel like I'm not just fucking go,
I'm not like being like do as I say,
not as I do.
That's what I did in this business.
I am self sufficient in this business.
If this business took everything away from me,
I could still be a standup comedian and do my podcast.
I'm completely self employed.
Those two things make me the most amount of money and I could easily live off
either reverse.
I got a TV show,
I have a cartoon calledF is for family,
but I was never dumb enough to be like,
well I got a TV show now and quit standup comedy.
Like I saw so many comedians do because eventually your show goes off the air
and those fucking residual checks dwindled down to like,
you know,
I get residual checks routinely for like under $3.
So,
um,
I'm trying to say this to empower you,
but you know,
quit your fucking whining.
All right?
There's all these studies out there that clearly show that women are smarter
than men.
So if you smarter than us,
then you can build a better mouse trap.
So get together with some of your smart lady friends and start a fucking
business.
But for the love of God,
quit your fucking whining.
Everybody out there is eating a giant shit sandwich.
Now granted there might be less shit my sandwich than yours,
but make no mistake,
it's still a shit sandwich.
All right?
But there's nothing stopping you from picking out the bread.
Um,
cause when you do start your own business,
um,
you're going to work more than you have to work.
That whole thing where it's like I will start my business and then I will
delegate and it will run on its own and I'll sit on a fucking yacht.
Yeah.
And they will rob you blind
anyways.
Um,
sexual aggressions.
all right,
but you,
I think you guys make up more than makeup for sexual aggressions.
Whatever the fuck that means.
Okay.
Is that sexual assault?
Are we talking about were the ones who have to have an opening line?
Um,
I think you guys more than make it up with a divorce court aggressions.
Okay.
And your whole fucking thing where you know,
I wish that women could just beat the shit out of guys instead of just taking
every fuck cause an ass kicking.
It's like you know a week of Epson salt.
Do you go to the dentist?
You can put it behind you.
All right,
but when a woman kicked should kicks your ass.
It just,
they do know.
They just take everything.
Everything.
The house,
the kids you could tar collection,
your car,
whatever the fuck you collect that you love,
they're going to make you sell that.
Not even cause they need the fucking money.
Just cause they know it's going to put another fucking hole in your heart.
Alright,
so there you go.
So here we go.
I'm going to go fucking play my little violin.
As I listened to the rest of this,
I agree with George Carlin,
my hero when he said 99%
of all the truly horrifying shit going on in this world was initiated,
established,
perpetrated,
enabled or continued by men.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But that's only because women haven't been given an opportunity to show how
fucking out of their minds they are.
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't understand why to compliment a woman you have to trashmen men
anyways.
He says,
and in the course of lives compared with men and women have far more to put up
with,
they bear greater burdens,
extra spoonfuls of Shit.
Oh boy.
Um,
I don't 100% agree with that.
Disagree with Louis C K that men are the number one threat to women.
Men are the number one cause of injury and may hem to women and men are the
worst thing that ever happens to women.
Yeah,
but you can say that right back to about women to men.
Yeah.
No one can fucking destroy a man's life like a woman.
Look at all of these fucking powerful men who,
who ascend the fucking mountain top and what brings him down
marrying the wrong fucking woman or fuck your life over worse than cancer.
Um,
anyways,
I do not,
I do not know any woman who is not done in some way physically and emotionally
assaulted in minimalized by men.
I don't know any guy out there who's dated a fucking woman and hasn't had his
hard fucking stepped on.
See what you're doing here,
sweetheart,
is you just looking out your own head?
Okay.
There's the Yin and the Yang.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I've never seen a happier woman out there then when she actually meets a great
man and vice versa.
They,
there's,
there's a positive way to look at this and in this age where they just
constantly trashing men and we can just hashtag white male trash,
which is you're combining racism and sexism and you're being called a fucking
hero about it.
I don't get it unless you're just going to fight fire with fire.
I don't know.
So anyways,
I would like to teach my daughters to defend themselves from physical aggression
and belittling comments from men.
Now this I agree with,
yeah,
it's called fucking MMA.
Get your kid involved in mixed martial arts.
Get your kid involved in sports,
big believer in that.
Um,
however,
I do not do not want to make them biased against men as I want to raise
confident,
polite women who view men as their equal but no one to defend themselves when
necessary.
Um,
well I gotta be honest with you.
Uh,
if you've looked at the millennial generation,
they've turned Manhattan into bed,
bath and beyond the vibe.
I mean,
older generations literally turned it into a giant bed bath and beyond bud.
Like,
I mean,
I never thought I'd say this,
but I feel like the standup scene is better in la than it is in New York,
just as far as the grown factor.
I get way more groans in New York City.
It's unreal.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
you had a dollar recently and I would love to know your opinion on what you will
say to your daughter about defending themselves without making them psychotic or
biased against men because of the news.
The me too movement.
The wage cap in my own personal experiences,
unfortunately I find myself more and more and enraged with the opposite sex.
Yeah.
That's because you're just being inundated with these fucking images.
It's also why you probably think everybody in the Middle East,
it's a fucking terrorist because that's all they're showing.
You know,
social media is a massive failure and there's all these studies coming out now
that show that it actually,
it,
you know,
it makes you angry,
it makes you depressed.
It's not a good thing.
Um,
anyways,
I certainly do not want to pass that onto my daughter under any circumstances.
I've talked to my husband a little bit about this,
but I do not want to tell them the extent of my disappointment in the male
species because I plan to stay with them for the rest of my life.
I would love to know your opinion and especially you defensive men so that I
have a different point of view any more but balanced opinion of men that I can
pass on to my daughter when I grow up.
Thank you very much psi and from Spain.
And I apologize for any grammatical or spelling errors as my English is not my
native language.
Um,
well first of all,
um,
like
the way that you wrote all of this and just sit in there,
treat and say one good fucking thing that men do and our even trashing men to
the level that you do.
You still playing the victim here.
And I have to sit here and do some tap dance for you to try to figure out why
your fucking life is actually also great because of men.
Go Fuck Yourself.
It's not my job to not make you a sexist content.
All right?
I get it.
You hate men.
What am,
what am I going to do?
They evidently you don't like central air conditioning.
He all modes of transportation,
modern medicine,
fucking some of the greatest music ever produced.
I mean,
we,
we have done some good things out there.
Okay?
Jesus Christ,
a couple of flashes and a few thousand fucking wars and all of a sudden all your
good deeds are just gone.
I don't know what to tell you.
All I can tell you is I feel bad for your daughter and I feel really bad for
your husband,
um,
that you basically don't like men.
MMM.
I gotta be honest.
She's as much as I trash women,
I realized that most of my shit is fear based.
MMM.
Because I grew up with a bunch of men that feared women.
And uh,
and then I also got into this business where most of us get divorced and I
watched
so much shit go down
that is really fucked up and it's just everybody just looks the other way.
Um,
but having said that,
the older I get,
the more I realize,
yeah.
How wrong I was about women.
All right.
Having said that,
now I'm not walking down the street,
not having my guard up either.
You know,
I am a big believer is you should like,
if you're a nice person,
if you're a good person,
you have to let people earn the fact that you're a nice person.
You just don't give that away because,
um,
when you're a really nice person who's openminded you become a psycho magnet.
And some of the worst people ever are going to really going to come into your
life because they need someone as nice and as forgiving because everybody else
is not going to put up with their bullshit.
Um,
but a lot of shit that I've said about women has been 100% in the wrong.
and I understand that.
So,
um,
I don't know,
you kind of sound like where you,
where I was at about 10 years ago with the opposite sex and you're also kind of
making yourself out to be a hero.
MMM.
I don't know.
I Dunno,
when I see guys on stage trashing men like that,
I always just think they just trying to get laid,
you know what I mean?
This whole fucking thing that oh man down days man.
Then that,
yeah,
they have,
we also done a lot of great thanks to him.
We also have done a lot of great fucking takes to,
okay.
And at the end of the day,
to always be talking about women as victims and in these victim positions is not
empowering to women.
All right.
To just sit around and just say,
all of my problems are,
becomes of a male dominated society.
Like where is that going to get?
And then your solution is to just bitch about men and then hashtag white male
trash.
Okay.
MMM.
As white male trash here.
I can tell you we're not having any meetings concerned about any of that shit.
Um,
it just fucking talking to other women that believe the same way you do.
Okay.
In life.
If you want to get out of your situation,
you have to fucking take control of it.
All right?
If you don't like working from men,
start your own thing.
All right?
I don't like working for other people.
That's why I do this and this is why I do stand up and we'll continue to do
that.
So you always have to have that ability to be like,
well,
that's the deal you're offering me.
Yeah,
I don't want it.
Go Fuck yourself and you walk away.
So,
um,
what would you do for your daughter?
I would,
first of all,
I would not give her a probably 90% of your negative opinions on men because
she'll become a man hater.
But it's your kid if that's what you want.
And I would,
um,
okay.
I Dunno if I was running shit,
I would secretly teach every woman out there,
uh,
mixed martial arts
and um,
and then that Israeli fucking martial arts shit,
we,
you disarm people that have weapons,
you know,
I think where they got a gun in your facing you that a little fun moving,
all of a sudden you're holding the gun,
pointing it at them.
MMM.
Yeah.
That type of shit.
Um,
I would also tell,
uh,
your daughter to never go back to a hotel room,
but the guy ever,
ever,
ever guys do not want to talk to you.
If guys want to talk and they go hang out with the fellas.
Okay.
They're trying to fuck you.
That's it.
And we ain't,
let's go back to hotel room.
Just talk.
That's just part of him trying to get you back there.
MMM.
I don't know.
I feel bad for your husband.
That's all I can tell you,
cause I just inserted myself into that thing.
So it's like,
oh my God,
you know,
you didn't say one positive thing about men and he just wrote a giant fucking,
there wasn't one positive thing in there.
And,
and the worst thing about where we're at right now is human beings.
She would be complimented on that and you'd be called strong.
And that's the direction that we're headed.
Um,
you know,
and you don't want,
I don't dictate it,
so
I dunno.
I guess mixed martial arts and I teach her how to run a business and along the
way,
you know,
if you don't know how to do that,
I would learn that too.
So you don't have to work for men.
Uh,
for the record.
Men treat other men like shit too,
by the way.
And that whole feminist fucking idea that,
uh,
if a guy's a dick that he gets respect,
like,
uh,
it's the stupidest thing ever.
And no one likes a dick.
No one wants to work for a dick.
And everybody secretly hopes the guy crashes on the fucking way home.
Hey,
you know what?
I loved about my boss.
He treated me like shit and I don't know why.
I just really respected him.
Nobody likes being treated like shit.
That is something a woman made up because it fit their fucking argument and
everybody ran with it.
Yeah.
If you're acting like an asshole,
you're an asshole.
All right.
Joe Rogan is going to get you killed.
The fuck is this?
All right.
I'm bill burr on the podcast 11 1617 you said,
I still can't wrap my head around the fact that I can eat this much.
Me.
Oh God.
Here we go.
Here's another fucking nutritionist with no fucking background whatsoever.
It's not going to tell me everything that I watch is now bullshit,
right?
Is that what this is going?
Okay,
because you can't bill,
I know you love,
I know you love your buddy Joe Rogan.
However,
your buddy,
the self proclaimed conspiracy theorists,
so am I.
Is dead wrong about nutrition.
All that meat and animal saturated fats will line your arteries with disease
laden plaque to not eat this stuff in abundance.
Minimize it.
Forget the notion of moderation too.
That's all horse shit.
This is right here at this.
I'm telling you,
they like religious nuts.
All of it is horseshit.
Explain the French then,
and they're rich diet and their lack of fucking heart disease over there.
That's it.
There's elements of truth in everything.
And the second you're going to sit there and tell me that your diet is the Diet.
Okay?
I don't know.
It's all horse shit.
The bulk of your cattle calories should be from beans,
peas and legumes,
vegetables,
fruits,
nuts and seeds and whole grains.
Crush waters and eat your salads as per usual of course,
but add walnuts,
pumpkin seeds,
blueberries,
mushrooms,
potatoes,
sweet potatoes and Greens to your daily routine,
as well as countless other whole foods of your choice.
Minimalize all oils,
pro process foods.
Who doesn't know about processed foods,
meats,
dairy,
and eggs.
I don't care where the fuck they come from.
Like Rogan's elk from the mountains of gods or wherever the fuck he hunts.
Um,
go.
Nutrition facts.org now,
did you vet nutrition facts.org?
Do you know where this came from for all published nutritional science in all of
these steam peer review?
We're worldwide rural,
uh,
reviewed worldwide medical journals and science papers.
Yeah,
buddy.
They have blood money behind them.
Okay?
I'm not saying it's all bullshit,
but there is an element of bullshit in there.
The food industry
fucking lines,
those people's pockets.
He said forget the nonsense from the media advertising in these pseudoscience
pushing fruitcakes like Rogan.
I know he means well.
He means well,
but he's wrong.
Look at the works of Dr Joel Fermin,
Dr. Michael Greger,
Dr John [inaudible] two will Dr. Dean Ornish,
Dr Cardwell,
I can even read this guy's name,
Ellison and others just looking out for your buddy.
Okay.
Tell you what.
Thanks for looking out for me.
I'm going to do what the fuck I've been doing anyways cause I have low blood
blood pressure,
you know,
I'm doing fine and I'm keeping the weight off.
All right?
I'm not going to just sit there eating two handfuls of fucking Bacon,
all right?
But uh,
you know,
and I'm also not going to just eat a plant based diet.
I'm not doing that.
I'm going to continue to do what the fuck I'm doing because it's working for me.
And with all due respect,
sir.
And no point there,
did you say you were any sort of nutritionist?
You just read a bunch of shit that made sense to you.
All right.
And then you also went to bike,
you went to the,
the,
the mainstream fucking thing.
And that mainstream thing has a bunch of money behind it.
Okay.
From people in the food fucking industry that want to sell the food that they
grow.
So that place is also naturally perforated or corrupt.
I'm not saying it's all bullshit,
but there is an element of bullshit.
Would you not agree in that?
Is elements of bullshit and every fucking thing including this Goddamn podcasts.
I don't listen to me either.
All right.
And he's the last one here.
Accidentally killed girlfriend's cat.
Don't know what to do.
Uh,
Billy chode,
that's something I never found funny.
That word showed,
it's like a certain portion of like part of the country that thinks is,
that's a funny fucking word.
Um,
which I believe is like a short,
fat dick
got myself into a little bit of a moral dilemma.
I'd appreciate some advice.
My girlfriend of seven months,
seven months has an outdoor cat who was really smart and could always find a way
back home.
Anyways,
you can probably see where this is going,
where I can see where it's going in the title.
He said he accidentally killed your girlfriend's cat.
I'm driving to replace place less than a block away.
Not really watching the road and I hit the fucking thing.
Died on impact practically in two pieces a week.
That's all we can all pray for her.
A quick death.
I hit the fucking thing.
All right.
Uh,
but my
okay
girl had this cat for some four years and has a serious emotional attachment.
I'm not trying to be the asshole who killed her cat.
So I had a couple of sturdy plastic bags in my car,
a towel and a water bottle.
Sounds like you just came from the gym and I said,
and a seven 11 and without getting into the gritty details within 10 minutes
look like nothing ever happened,
I chucked it into a dumpster a few blocks away.
Oh God.
Good.
Get a car wash to be extra cautious and drive back to her place.
So,
ah,
it's been two weeks and I haven't told her she's freaking posted at least 30
missing cat photos all around the neighborhood and anywhere even remotely
nearby,
fucking crying and all of that shit.
It's messing with my conscious and our sex life.
There's the Gulf,
you go,
you're selfish bastard.
I feel like if she knows it's a dead zone,
she'll be able to move on.
But also with me covering it up for so long,
I'd be in a good bit of trouble.
So to say the least.
Help me out here on what I should do.
Um,
yeah,
dude.
Uh,
the,
the SS coming clean,
that ship's sailed.
That ship's sailed right after you cleaned up the crime scene and threw it in a
fucking dumpster is what you do.
You don't say a fucking word.
It's over,
dude.
It's over.
There's no do you let her cry for two fucking weeks and you knew that it's over.
Um,
and then I'll see you after you got to ask yourself,
am I going to marry this person?
Okay.
All right.
Here's the deal.
If you're going to marry this person,
don't ever fucking tell her.
All right.
If you don't want to marry this person,
you got to do a,
you got to do a two for one here.
Okay.
All right.
You have to break up with her and then also tell her that you killed their cat,
but not in that order.
You tell her that you killed her chat.
All right.
And then hopefully she'll break up with you.
Oh,
way too open with killing or cat.
Yeah.
Oh Dude,
this,
no,
I don't know if year this is around the holidays.
I think you got to do it.
No,
if you want to stay with her,
if you love her,
are you going to marry this woman?
She's going to marry this woman.
Don't tell her you killed a cat if you're not going to marry a woman that I,
you know,
I dunno.
I know there's a lot of people also horrified by this fucking story,
but like,
I mean,
the cat was dead.
Okay,
what were we supposed to do here?
Hey man,
you should have told her.
But I mean,
as far as like throwing the thing in the dumpster,
I mean,
if I die and somebody shows me a dump,
so I don't give a shit.
My biggest concern is how bad I'm going to smell it.
That parking lot.
Other than that,
I'm dead.
Don't need some fancy fucking box.
You know,
I don't understand that.
When people die and they put them in these,
these beautiful fucking caskets,
it's like,
it's a piece of fruit that went bad,
you know,
and you're putting it on display,
throwing the fucking trash.
All right,
that's disgusting.
Okay.
That's the end of the podcast here.
I'm happy thanksgiving.
Everybody do your cardio,
eat your salads.
Um,
go nuts on thanksgiving,
but hit it again right on Friday.
Alright,
get after it.
Um,
I wish I could actually meet that woman from Spain and we could sit down and I
talk about all my fucking women hating shit and she could talk about our guy
hate should,
maybe we can fucking find a middle ground,
um,
before we both fuck up our daughters.
Um,
no,
I would never say anything negative about women to my daughter.
I would.
All right.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Happy Turkey day and I'll check in on you on Thanksgiving.
Look at that.
And not even taking a day off.
All right,
I'll see you.